the icy grip of the beast from the east
a Siberian blast that broke temperature
records and cloaked much of the country
in deep snow
it's officially spring but is
[Applause]
the extreme weather we're seeing here
has its origins thousands of miles away
over the Pacific Ocean an atmospheric
journey that scientists are only just
beginning to understand
[Applause]
[Music]
the big freeze of 2018 from the Brecon
Beacons in south wales to the north east
of england the biting easterly winds
turned britain into an outpost of the
arctic thank you
many will never have seen conditions
like it the everyday became the
extraordinary
from the air you got a sense of the
scale from Scotland to stop in England
from the East of England to Ireland
there seems to be virtually no County
which is untouched even the crew that
I'm flying with today say that they
haven't seen such widespread blankets of
snow up and down the country in nearly a
decade since 2010 even meteorologists
got excited the last few days
temperatures have been minus 2 minus 3
and when you factor in that windchill it
actually feels more like minus 8 minus 9
degrees outside on Wednesday night
temperatures plummeted to minus 13
degrees Celsius down in Kent that's 8
degrees Fahrenheit and has been
unseasonable cold and dry start to watch
it's unusual weather that scientists
have traced back to events four weeks
ago over the Pacific Ocean 5,000 miles
away slight variations in the pattern of
tropical thunderstorms send waves
through the atmosphere
all the way to the Arctic where 18 miles
up it caused what scientists calls
sudden stratospheric warming normally a
low-pressure system called the polar
vortex it's over the region with 150
mile an hour westerly winds trapping the
icy polar air but the waves traveling
through the atmosphere flipped the winds
so they now flowed from the east
this caused the air in the stratosphere
to collapse squeezing together the air
molecules and the temperature soared by
50 degrees during winter time what
happens is you know the stratosphere
over the pole gets really really cold
temperatures and this is when the
stratosphere is getting extremely cold
at the same time the stratospheric polar
vortex really spins up so we have really
really strong circulation going around
the pole and what you can see is right
through winter all the way to winter we
have strong cold temperatures at their
strong polar stratospheric cortex and
then all of a sudden the beginning of
February it just plummets it just warms
up we have what's called a certain
stratospheric warming so what's
happening is there's various soft waves
coming up from the atmosphere it's
trying to disturb the polar vortex and
all of a sudden the polar vortex just
breaks down we get
rapid warming there and all those winds
just slow right down and this was about
50 degrees in just a day quite quite
unusual to see something to that extent
yeah it's a huge event these things
happen maybe once every five years
they're really quite rare and this this
is a particularly large one it's a
really interesting one and as soon as
the polar stratospheric vortex breaks
down those winds go yeah it's like a
break on top of the top of the
troposphere where our weather occurs and
as soon as that happens then we get
changes in the jet stream and we can see
the impact of that when we pull up the
the next you can see animation that is
the cold air which is yes so what's
happened is as the the sudden stress
rate wormans occurred then the jet
stream is slowed right down and all this
cold air suddenly starts to move slowly
and towards towards the UK across Europe
so we start to see all that really
really cold air from Russia coming
towards us quite sure I'm gonna feed
these to the snow swept in from the
North Sea the east of the UK took the
brunt at first
roads quickly became treacherous
this was a heart-stopping moment for a
driver in Edinburgh others when said
lucky on the motorways vehicle struggled
to grip the slippery surface he
conquered traction first slowing and
then coming to a halt
I see the way to the buck yet your
front-end drive makes it light I'll dig
you out a little bit yeah I'll tell you
when [ __ ] tight traffic cop Aziz did
what they could to dig them out earlier
on he was cleared on the axle that broke
down without the vehicle on the floor
priority was mean anything lively and I
will call back to check on him later on
Ceres being recovered the Met Office
issued the first ever red weather
warnings first in Scotland then on
Thursday the southwest urging people to
stay indoors but the snow came so hard
and so fast but hundreds of cars got
trapped on the a303 in Wiltshire drivers
spent the night in their vehicles it's
quite hard to describe really
apocalyptic scenes we there's no
emergency services no critters on the
road and actually the kind of where
there hasn't been too bad but just a
lack of gritting just means that I mean
there are hundreds of trucks you know
cars listed everywhere you know being
past a burning cars is quite
extraordinary what can you see out the
window now you are you stuck in a
tailback or is it just that your car
just can't move because it's it's broken
down yeah so luckily I'm in a 4x4 so
we're at the bottom of a hill and the
less is kind of stacked up with lorries
so there's only kind of really one road
to go so the cars in front of us who
don't have 4x4 are getting stuck so
we're confident that we can move forward
but every time we get to a hill a car in
front of us get stuck so it's just a
real mess
[Music]
for highways England it was chaos people
through the night have abandoned the
cars locked the vehicles and walked off
with the keys now every single one of
those vehicles has to be lifted out of
the way before the critters can get can
get and move further and further up the
hill trains also struggled as the
weather closed in this London to
Bournemouth service got stuck with
passengers given space blankets to keep
warm we all came together and cabins
keep warm when the heater went down so
we one girl like she had gloves on her
feet I'm so cold we got water out like
what food we had left we go out as well
then we're all trying to you know keep
you to the happy because it was it was
started cold planes were grounded with
hundreds of flights delayed or cancelled
at Glasgow Airport crews tried to keep
the runways clear but the snow just kept
on coming some regions have seen 40
centimetres of snow whereas other
regions have seen just five centimetres
across the UK and what's happened is
you've got this very cold dry air coming
across from Scandinavia to the UK and it
moves across the North Sea which acts as
a moisture source which is what we need
for the snow now parts of Kent and East
Anglia some of them saw 20 centimeters
of snow and that's because the air that
was moving across there had a very long
C track and that allowed the air to gain
more moisture and dump much more snow
regions to the north and west of London
further inland the air becomes much
drier and the showers dry up they become
less frequent and lighter and that's why
there's being less snow there but there
was time to enjoy the snow too
[Applause]
and there's plenty more time for fun the
forecasters for more cold weather at
least into next week the chill of 2018
has broken records and it's far from
over